my name is vera and welcome back to some
more start with sword rage v if you kill
aw hey bye hey man what's your name
no well your face is second alright
o power double star power all right who
wants double star power trapezoid power
nipple just pregnant but start our
that's what I'm talking about
alright get the fat lady aha
what are you doing my god catch the leg
catch the bad leg I got a little egg
back catch I always wanted a fat leg hmm
I always wanted to inject the fat leg
into another fat leg my dreams are
coming true Santa what are you doing
stop dangling said I told you don't make
me kill you Santa I have a fat leg over
here but I stashed it or that guy let's
see if we can kill everyone all right
that's your peanuts not your [ __ ] leg
look at that guy is a ketchup bottle all
right just make sure we killed bro
Jonathan I missed that's fine though bro
trap us our power to shut the light what
the hell is going on down there just Pro
get pro get throw we got throw and I got
a leg again
[ __ ] your legs [ __ ] off what are you
doing in fact Horsa and now we kill
ourselves for the grand finale all right
I can't do it but whatever it's not a
project you're all suck
all right longest spike fall hello there
this is my second level of spikes well
I'm glad you contribute all right watch
me do it on the first try I don't care
all right second tribe [ __ ] there we
go
okay hanky hey I'm Petey all right watch
me do it watch me do it ah my eyes on
this dock ah got it
nice stuck again got a nice second guess
by doing this to myself
got it got one gun what what am i doing
you go Vespa what what are we doing
Messner
I spoke to stop it front slip best way
don't leave me Oh son of a [ __ ] Vespa
here we go this is perfect just watch
this one it's not the longest spike
follow right you're a liar
all right this one will make it this one
will make it this one will make it
[ __ ] yeah that's how I roll
Pro butter run I'm a pro start touching
my ass a little bit
yeah no no [ __ ] by the neck is not
broken I tell you if it's [ __ ] on
let's go [ __ ] yeah let's go oh you came
back there son
shred flap table front snap trap on
stress John
go bite into it ain't no pile a cup to
the power party my legs became a ketchup
bottle
breakdancing back let's tie this again
what no I want to go with you come here
stop breaking go ahead you suck bye
that's how I roll alright let's go boy
[ __ ] yeah what what what oh alright I
can do it I can do it try a shot
alright here we go here's ready for this
bike ah [ __ ] my neck extreme double
backflip alright
punch you back there we go your mom came
that's how awesome that was it looks
like I don't know which monster where
are you going son
what the [ __ ] are you god damn sorry you
little [ __ ] I'll eat you up demo alright
whoa look sorry yeah how's it going bad
nom nom nom nom nom I'll eat you I don't
know what you're doing damn it
and I shot game another but for us this
is for expect me do it on it at least I
have a cut up you don't know how to
handle in the beginning thanks goes out
to Nadia I'm hopping out [ __ ] yeah
alright seriously
what how do you do and give yourself a
big gang what the [ __ ] was that bye
what the hell is that [ __ ] that's how I
roll hi how are we doing going stop it
make me stop no no I hate you bye
[ __ ] hate you what the hell happened
there this is [ __ ] head
another bottle run come on alright this
is the last one I'll do frickin butter
Raj every way gennadi ah yeah [ __ ] yeah
easy
alright [ __ ] ya gon gone yeah come on we
always made it come on you can do it by
come on mind you suck man alright stop
ejecting yourself dad white booth come
on oh it's a sad dejected both or
control age x2 I know what I'm gonna
make it anyway alright
god damn it it's difficult when you
don't have aa come on
whoa we did it close enough
alright a glass rider that sounds pretty
good
whatever makes it first I would put your
name right yeah but names dad do ya
you don't know what's faster do you a
little pudgy I didn't raise a peasant
alright okay bro you better be pro one
day I'll [ __ ] kill ya look at that
master the problem if you make alright
thank God I had by I [ __ ] hate you
you better diet I just [ __ ] hardest
what should we do it on the first try ah
there we go
you just gotta relax your body make it
move the way you want it to that's why
you go make me proud best back oh and
that's how I roll ah
Tobuscus while we're at it alright let's
see how much I know but Toby what's
Tobuscus this real name
Nathan Jackson I knew it no no don't go
down there don't best back ah I didn't
take me legally die I know I think it's
yeah it's the ob come on man
they could add more than two of the
questions in my opinion back alright
what is Toby Turner I'm not well these
dogs names Griffin or aristocraft
arrestor crap no it's not I was just
kidding I wanted to see what's on the
other side alright
come on now that if Akash here we go
it's it's Griffin I knew that I knew
that for shizzle all right how old is
totally 27 or 30 it authority
I'd say 27 all right come on come on
come on yeah no gotta make it JA quit or
I just stink Chris Josh make me laugh
who gives [ __ ] I'm sorry
level one oh my god whoa by DZ first
about Ming I'm back I'm going back there
I'm going back girl cuz I rock your I
bet the glass is gonna be gun now man
even moving
I am yep control bah
nailed it - easy - easy Chuck oh yeah
slow what [ __ ] that well holy [ __ ]
we're what let's not let's keep going
best but no what are you doing don't you
make that's right ha you missed
slow and I brought us out of a [ __ ] no
I can't stop best for there's a bank no
god damn it one try come on I hate this
[ __ ] best buy pump all right best bah
alright slow they go ah ah don't worry
it's not gonna stop me you and me best
man no no no no no
all right we get ya know ain't no party
like a PewDiePie party think he's gonna
stop me ha got Michael Jackson legs me
back ok don't die go die business what
the hell is this
I'm humping my own body oh yeah [ __ ] a
penetration depression when you realize
what you deal with your life you just
realize that your butt is trying to hump
Bovespa
that's never again never gonna stop it
less bad stop it don't cheat on me baby
girl direct me love that [ __ ] and now
there's a road here probably man yeah
suck it legs
I don't need legs finish this map what
what what what leg out I had a little
foot you have a new leg cool alright we
finish this together ass back this is
love right here laughing justice I saw
that matters in life
Viking holy [ __ ] [ __ ] my son that's
pop I know I'm sexy [ __ ] stop trying to
tidy it looks like it's Kida staying or
some [ __ ] like that yeah
okay no it's fine
yeah I love that bye
come on no no what are you doing what am
i some acrobatics oh oh and we did it
what there we go face flat directory
alright that was pretty much it for
today Russ but like for you enjoyed it
helps out a lot subscribe to come
umbrella today I know you want to I want
you to stay awesome Rose I know you